rank
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
take it away
grand prairie texas i'll be in your city
it's near dallas i will be in your city
friday
it is friday it is friday is when i'll
be there and august 26th
and it is time to get tickets now
because it is either wednesday or
thursday when you're listening to this
or even friday so coming out to the show
i'm there with the crew um and then
wichita
august 27th on saturday i will be there
with the crew
and then i will come home for two weeks
and go to atlanta that's sold out
uh and then i will go to washington d.c
september 10th i don't know how many
tickets are left for that or i i think
there's some left but uh those are the
ones and then we gotta go stockton and
oakland dude it's just gonna keep
going on and on i guess i don't know
sometimes um i think about when i will
retire really honestly you know um
because i don't know how long you're
supposed to do stand up i know you know
seinfeld is out there still doing it and
[ __ ] uh
other guys are out there still doing it
uh and
i don't know i don't know i [ __ ] love
it maybe it'll be a thing where i kind
of back off and don't do as much as you
know i used to do shows [ __ ] man like
three times a night like they're like i
mean i would get sho i would do shows i
had these on as a joke but now i'm
actually not i'm being serious um
i would do shows uh three times a night
man i mean i was probably doing like 15
shows a week
that wasn't uncommon and now i don't you
know i do maybe
three
i think i did actually five or six this
week but that's because i'm getting
ready for the tour
um
so yeah we'll be there we also have
exclusive merch at on the tour that is
only able you're only able to get it we
have the life rips uh
live and the uh what do you call it the
uh
is it don't push me live with the dates
on it it's really [ __ ] cool i'm
excited about it oh also these came out
the brown version of the [ __ ]
worldwide shits um and we got we got
[ __ ] uh the whole set dude i love the
sets man you know falls coming
and uh this set's
[ __ ] unbestankable dude that's a new
word
uh it's unbelievable
with the [ __ ] sweats oh they're nice
as [ __ ] they're comfy wear them on
flights anyway um so go to chris
leah.com and get all that [ __ ] i don't
know why i show it to you when we got
the pictures right here anyway
um
but yeah man we have a good time so i'll
be out and doing tours and [ __ ] last one
i went to was phoenix
thanks um last one i went to was phoenix
and that [ __ ] was unbelievable um we had
a good time we did two there and uh and
that's what's up i guess man
what's been going on this week uh well i
did a bunch of shows first of all let me
just thank you guys for listening um i'm
feeling really grateful today
you know i want to be uh appreciative to
you guys uh i'm feeling good about life
i'm feeling grateful um you know
some days are a struggle and um you know
i think about
mental health a lot more lately um and
uh you know it's uh it's hard i let the
stuff get to me sometimes in the world
and um just want to be a [ __ ]
somebody that uh
does you know does the right thing does
good in the world and it's a [ __ ] you
know it's tough dude you know
i want you know what i want to be
for real i decided this the other day
i want to be religious i want to be a
guy who's like uh uh like believes in
god
and just goes to church sometimes
and but he's like one of those cool
dudes that's like yeah you know you
don't have to believe in god but i do i
don't want to have to push it on you and
[ __ ]
but i want to have i want to believe in
something man
i've been thinking about this the other
day
and i told my friends and they laughed
dude and it was funny but i
i meant it dude it is funny to hear me
say that but also i mean it i wish there
was something
you know that i could uh
believe in like a higher power you know
and there is
there are like my friends or my family
you know something that's greater than
myself that i can i can i can rely on
and that can help me and those are
that's my family that's my my crew you
know um
but
it sucks because no matter how much i
want to believe in god there's always
that thing
that there where it's like
okay i want it to be proven and then
people are like but hey dude that's what
faith is and i'm like that
just can we get a little bit of proof
though right
can we get a little bit of proof though
can one day jesus just be like and you
look over and it's jesus and then he
goes
and you're like
okay i well
okay i have faith i have faith and then
religious people will be like but that's
not faith though because you saw jesus
and then you'll say stuff to like
religious people like well i've never
seen jesus and then i'll be they'll say
some annoying ass [ __ ] like what can you
see air but you know it's there
and you're just like jesus christ okay
i can't talk to you
but all of these feelings how could you
feel all these feelings without a jesus
how could you feel all of these feelings
without a higher power and you know what
dude maybe and i'm not the guy who's
like no no no no there's no jesus or
there's no god i should stop saying
jesus there's different religio uh
religions there's no god
right
i can't say there's no god
how the [ __ ] do i know who the [ __ ] do i
think i am to know about that
whoa he's starting off hot
but i want to be religious hey dude
i want to jump in the lake
right
i want to put all my clothes in and jump
in the lake
and i have another man pet my head
i guess i'm just not there yet man
i hope i am
really because you see religious people
around and they're [ __ ]
you know they got their their battles
and [ __ ] but they walk around and they
know
something else is out there
and maybe it's not but they know it is
and that's good enough for them dude
and here's the other thing man
i never really believed in heaven
because
my idea of heaven is you get there and
you chill and you have a good time
there's a lot of turkey sandwiches
people give you massages mostly women
and you're just kind of [ __ ] watching
a bunch of tv that doesn't really matter
right not like important shows like
[ __ ] in the lexicon like game of
thrones like you're watching fear thy
neighbor
or you know some dumb documentary that
has four episodes about like game stop
you're watching that
but kristen's idea of heaven is not that
it's like there's there's we're not
watching that
she's like scrolling through tick tock
and like
the house is decorated in a way that i
don't want it to be
so how the [ __ ] are we gonna be there
together
don't husbands always want to be in
heaven with their wives i mean probably
not but i do
so what is it say you got eight kids and
you love all of them but two of them
hate you you want them in heaven they
don't want to be in your heaven
so then what
but i want to believe it dude
my buddy said to me one time
you know because a lot of people are
like well when you get to heaven you get
to have all the the women you want and
all the sex you want and then my buddy
said dude when i get to heaven i want
that sexual urge removed from me i want
to be stress-free and i was like that's
the ticket dude
that's the ticket man that's my heaven
but i don't really believe in heaven and
i want there to be a heaven dude
but that's the thing about religion even
if there is no heaven who's it hurting
besides all the [ __ ] wars and [ __ ]
you know what i mean besides the people
literally dying and [ __ ] like literally
being [ __ ] shot and burned and
[ __ ] cut off their heads and all the
wars through all of humanity besides
that the day-to-day [ __ ] of it when
you're running into a religious guy he's
not a piece of [ __ ] he's just living his
own life smiling
it's a very convoluted and intricate
thing to think about at least for me man
but i'm a dumb ass
i just wish there was something out
there that i could [ __ ] really get
behind man you know and it's my kid
right
but he's real i can see him right there
i don't know
it's just what i've been thinking of
lately man you know
and then i [ __ ] get into the car on
the way back from the doctors and the
valet guy that brought it like is like
have a good day and i'm like i'm going
to give him this much of a tip and then
i go you know what i'm actually going to
give him more of a tip because what the
[ __ ] does it matter to me and he'll
probably be more happy so i give him
more of a tip and then i get in the car
dude and it smells like a [ __ ]
department store
[Music]
dracar noir all over the guts dude i
swear to god it was like he [ __ ] got
ready in my car this morning
he goes [ __ ] let me get your mercedes
in his mouth dude and then drove up and
said thank you sir gave him a little bit
more money because what's it matter to
me and then [ __ ] got in the car and
wished i didn't but ain't that just how
life goes
[Music]
i had to open up all the windows and
[ __ ] drive around town
um
a manly cologne is just awful i mean all
cologne and perfume is just awful
uh but i did i went to the doctors and
um
and it was uh great dude went to the
doctor dude i got a jokey ass doctor
i'll tell you that much i got a jokey
ass doctor you ever have a jokey ass
doctor and i don't want this [ __ ]
sounds like a bit it's not a bit i'm not
even going to get into it but i got a
jokey ass doctor and that's it i don't
want to get into it and that's fine
that's for me to know i have that
experience with him he's a great [ __ ]
surgeon when it comes to nasal shits
cause guess what [ __ ] yeah dude my nose
is better
[Applause]
i thought it wasn't going to be better
and you were along for that ride with me
weren't you you thought it might not be
better i was complaining it was hard is
it worth the
i used to when i would [ __ ] i would
hold my nose like this
if i
i would hold my one my nostril if i
could only breathe through this nostril
with no mouth i would end up passing out
i'd have to release my thumb and now i
can do it for [ __ ] i can just do it i
can just hold my thumb there like that
so if you see me picture me out there
like that not passing out so he made it
work now was it worth the money probably
not but he said i'll live longer so okay
if i get to live longer to be with my
[ __ ] you know
be with the homies then that's what's up
because i don't believe in heaven but
maybe it does exist but maybe it does
exist dude
um
so yeah i went in and he checked it dude
and he didn't even numb at that time and
i was so happy dude i hate when he numbs
it i hate getting numbed up in there up
in that piece when they numb your
[ __ ] brain dude when they just stick
two prongs up there and i go what's that
and he says that's the numbing [ __ ] and
then my brain looks like [ __ ] it just
oh god i hate that [ __ ] i hate it more
than a surgery to be honest surgery you
don't even feel it you just pass the
[ __ ] out so it's all good my babies
um
anyway dude
so my nose is fixed it's still tender
and i every time i ask him why it's
still tender he says because i went in
there and i cut it up and i want more of
an explanation
yes dude and every time i ask him that's
what he says because i go in there and i
cut your whole face up he's too jokey
yes dude
tell me in doctor terms well the reason
is because the capillaries and this and
that and then i gotta i ended up you
know what it feels like when you get the
nose surgery the uh what is it called
not [ __ ] cynoplasty what did i get
cyno something not rhinoplasty sinus
whatever the [ __ ] it is cyanoseptic
septic sino septic tank
septoplasty got it [ __ ] yeah septoplasty
got it with no help um
septoplasty and you know what it feels
like dude for those of you that need to
get it because a lot of you apparently
85 people have deviated septums oh oh
oh
it's too many people what's everyone
running the [ __ ] into what did i run
into i don't know
i have no idea what i ran into i said
was i born like this and he said no
nobody's born like that and i said i ran
into something with my face and he said
yes and i said i don't remember he said
well that's what happened so i go okay
my brother has it too and i know why
because he ran into another person's
[ __ ]
the back of his head
and that's why he has it but 85 percent
of the people have it that doesn't mean
you need to have surgery right god damn
i talk so fast dude
but um that doesn't mean you need to
have surgery but what it does mean is
you might need to have surgery right
and i [ __ ] uh it's uh you know
it feels like you know what it feels
like after like a month and a half of it
it feels like you know when you floss
your teeth that's the kind of pain you
have in your in your nose and that's
awesome it feels good because it feels
good when you brush your teeth so it
feels good in my nose now i don't know
if everyone has that experience but i
told him that he goes yeah yeah that is
how it feels anyway dude whatever
he said his family came to my shows and
i had no [ __ ] idea and he was like i
didn't want to tell you because i didn't
want you to just fillet him he kept
saying what did he say i didn't want him
to [ __ ] i didn't want you to fillet him
what was it fellaium i think that's what
he was saying but he kept saying he's
like because i got a lot of comedian
patients that come in here and i send my
family to their shows and they just
absolutely fillet them
i didn't want to make you wig out and
i'm like yeah no it's all good it's just
a job but
he's a good doctor shout out to the
doctor in this theory um
so yeah
you know i don't know man
i was on uh
i was actually on uh i was on rick
glassman's podcast taking shoes off uh
and it's out there now and it's uh it
came out already because this will be
out and it was really good to sit down
and talk to him man i love that dude you
should go check out that podcast
actually you know what rick is one of
the silliest dudes i know and i would
say he thinks probably i'm one of the
silliest dudes he knows and we started a
little bit silly but boy did we actually
get [ __ ] not so silly man didn't
expect for that to happen you know
what's weird too about these podcasts
let me tell you what's weird about these
podcasts like we do podcasts comedians
they'll do each other's podcast and [ __ ]
and thank god sometimes it's like such a
hustle it's like okay i'll do yours you
do mine it's so [ __ ] annoying i think
i don't have any guests i don't have to
have people on here but also
like
these podcasts they're the only like
they're the only times these comedians
talk to each other
you know
the rest of the time they're just
talking at each other
or like hey how you doing what'd you
have for dinner this is the longest
conversation rick lastman i would
consider him a pretty damn good friend
i've known him for 15 years and i
haven't [ __ ] had a conversation with
him like this in forever
an hour
no an hour and 40 minutes
we talked
um
so yeah
i took calvin over to [ __ ] i was with
kristen and i took calvin over to color
me mine you know what color me mine is
um it's one of those places where you
can uh
go in
and pick a like a ceramic thing well and
they got all sorts of ceramic things
like anything from like ceramic spiders
to like coffee mugs to like um
uh
a vase to
a
hat you know you know not a hat you wear
but like a ceramic hat that you would
paint anything they have flowers they
have little village like mushroom
cottages and [ __ ]
and um
kristen was like i'm gonna take calvin
to color me mine and it's one of those
things where i'm like oh that's cool
that's like a mommy son thing but also i
secretly think she wants to go to color
me mine because she loves to do crafts
but it's a good thing for them to bond
with and also i want my son to be
[ __ ] i mean my son what boy he's
laser focused when he's drawing that
[ __ ] it looks like he's trying
to find an antidote for aids or some
[ __ ] i mean he's just serious will you
put him an etch-a-sketch in front of him
i mean my god dude
it's like he's [ __ ] um
tommy lee jones and been blown away
trying to make the last bomb i mean he's
[ __ ] with just classical music you
know
in the background
oh
so anyway she was like you want to join
us and i was like you know what dude
yes i
do yes i do
i want to join you
and paint with my son
now is this something that four years
ago chris leah would have done or would
have thought he would have done
will crystallia have thought
oh in four years i'm gonna go to color
me mine with my family
no
but i did
and i went and i showed up and i said
calvin what do you want to paint and he
said i want to paint this and picked up
a [ __ ] ceramic spider and i said are
you sure and he goes yes
and he says oh and he looks over at a
vase and he says look at that
and i said is that you want to put what
you want to paint and he picked up the
spider and he said no i'll paint this
and i said oh okay cool and then he
looks at the skull and he says oh
look at that dada and i said very cool
skull huh and then he picks it up and
says i'll paint this
so now i'm like hey
stop getting [ __ ] distracted and pick
something
because i want you to i want you to
paint what you want to paint
being a kid is the [ __ ] you know you
just do [ __ ] until you want to do
something else
right isn't that it you're just [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] until
something else you get a hankering for
something else right like the other day
my son ate candy and then turkey
hey guy
that's [ __ ] disgusting
don't the sweets deteriorate your tongue
and then you want cold cuts
you want to [ __ ] dude we got these
like you you want these you want those
[ __ ] sour pumpkins those sour pumpkin
those sour patch pumpkins and then
turkey and mustard what's going on in
your mouth
dude
but that's what he wanted and that's
what he did so he wanted a spider and
then he said he wanted a skull and i
asked him if he was sure three times and
he said yes so we took the skull and we
brought it over and then kristen got a
[ __ ] little um
what do you call it
pot that she wanted to paint because
she's like a real person and she's
thinking like i'll paint and i'll like
actually use it in my house which i'm
like she's one of those people that go
to color me mine to like that actually
like does like work
you know so so i'm sitting there and i'm
like what color do you want buddy and he
goes that one and he's putting all the
colors and he's putting like five at the
same colors i'm like buddy you gotta
pick different colors otherwise it's all
gonna look the same but secretly i'm
kind of happy that he's doing it because
i love being monochromatic you know me
dude i mean look at the new merch it's
fire and it's all brown dude pants and
shirt and hat
monochromatic till the [ __ ] cows come
home you know what i say
so um
so
so now
uh we pick different colors he starts
painting the skull oh and uh and and
kristen's like why don't you pick
something and i go i don't i don't i'm
just you know i'm along for the ride and
she says it's fun
and i know she means it's fun for her
and i should join because it's and i'm
like i don't really want to paint
something but maybe it's an experience i
should have
if you're like me dude you know what's
[ __ ] annoying as [ __ ] sometimes
experiences
like you figure [ __ ] out your whole life
you get to a point where you know what's
up and that's your life
and then people are like
you know you should join us on a retreat
and you're like
hey hey
i don't
do retreats
my [ __ ] is i wake up i get coffee i eat
a sandwich i do a show and then i
[ __ ] see what's up you know i see
what's up and you know what i mean by
see what's up because five years later i
was definitely seeing what's up right
five years earlier
five years later it went up 48.
and um
and so
now i'm like i you know
like you got to change in life dude if
you're not changing you're it's a death
of some sort
you have to keep growing and changing
and evolving and if you don't that's a
death of some sort right
i i think i don't think it's literal
that sometimes it is literal of death
right
what you love what you need to keep
doing that will kill you if you're not
living right but you need change
certainly if you're not living right but
you also need change even if you're
living some sort of life that you think
you figured out and you are living right
because if you're not i feel like that's
a death of
kind of exploration and creativity that
maybe
maybe
might benefit you
so i'm at color me mine
you know and maybe that's not somebody's
definition of changing their life but
you know what god dammit it is
because i don't go to color me mine and
i stepped in the place and i stepped in
a place to watch and as a matter of fact
i'm still changing because kristen said
why don't you paint something and i said
yes so i looked at the things on the
[ __ ] shelf and i'll be goddamn
there was a mug on it that said dad
so i picked up that mug
and they asked what colors i wanted
and i said green
and blue
and there's like nine spots for colors
on the [ __ ] palette thing there and
they said is that it
and then kristen said why don't you get
more colors just in case and in my head
i thought
one change at a time okay
and i looked at her and i said nope
just blue and green thanks
and i painted the cup green and the word
dad blue
and i did that while my son painted the
skull and all he did was paint the front
of the [ __ ] skull and he should have
painted [ __ ] more of it
[Music]
but you don't disturb an artist and if
that's what he wanted to do that's what
he wanted to do and yeah kristen ended
up [ __ ] filling in the rest but it's
okay do it wow this how it looks [ __ ]
legit look how [ __ ] cool i look dude
wow dude
look at that hat dude
so yeah man
that's what's up i got a mug i don't
know if i won't have it by the time this
step i'll have it next episode and i'll
be [ __ ] drinking out of it dude
dad city
it's cool man
i painted the handle green too
i painted the handle green and
everything green i had to go over it a
few times it's gonna look [ __ ] not so
good which is like you're actually doing
it really good and i'm like i don't need
that i don't need that baby
thank you let me just paint this i don't
really need that
oh man
oh [ __ ] i hit the [ __ ] thing all good
saw the new [ __ ] uh
oh while we were at [ __ ] i forgot
about this dude while we were at um
color me mine
dude there were these two
i'm gonna assume females
you know you gotta assume these you
can't assume but you gotta if you're
gonna tell a story about them right
you can't just be saying everyone's they
in this story then people are gonna be
like but what were they and you're like
well i don't know and then get out of
that conversation
so uh these two fem
two women i i think probably because
they looked there were women you know i
don't know i don't know what to do to
not get in trouble two
two people that were
you know
two people that had tits they had tits
and so and it's fine but and that's what
and not even in a sexual way they had
breasts how about that sounds sexual
they had breasts so two people had
breasts that colored me mine and they
were and they were adults they were like
you know 30
painting and i was like that's sweet
that they like to do that they meet each
other and they're at columbia mine and
the two
women probably they're there and they're
painting each other's [ __ ] they were
painting little like people looked like
kimberly they both picked keebler elves
houses and they were good dude they were
[ __ ] coloring it in and killing it
and they were both wearing masks and
that was one of the reasons why i
thought maybe maybe they're women but
maybe i shouldn't assume because let's
face it dude
the people who are really interested in
the pronoun stuff
most of the time we'll be wearing masks
indoors and i'm not touching like now
maybe not most of the time but i was
erring on the side of caution it doesn't
really matter to my podcast i got the
fan base it's all good and you're with
me okay but i'm gonna say that they were
probably women and i'm gonna roll with
that
and the reason why i say probably but
i'm not sure is because they had short
they both had short hair i don't want to
say
that
you know that's also a stereotype men
have short hair women have longer but
that's and i get it women could have
short hair men who have tits can have
short hair women who don't have tit you
know what i mean the whole gamut these
people had short hair and tits is what
i'm trying to get at
okay and they were painting though
keebler ells houses and whatever they
were they were killing it dude these
shits looked like i mean i saw kristen
look over and was like
oh yeah [ __ ] probably
you know what i mean
i could do oh you think oh really okay
well let me get my jar out and paint the
[ __ ] out of these diamonds on it
so
calvin
is a very curious boy dude it turns out
i raise very curious boys
when i splurt and they come out nine
months later they're very curious
so he
keeps pointing to the woman
and says
really loudly
what's he making
we're in a dilemma
and i say
oh
well that
is a little mushroom keebler else how
elf house
and he goes oh
and it happened
ten
[ __ ] times and kristen and i kept
side eyeing each other and hopefully
they weren't offended and in that sense
they make sense because there were two
of them my baby i'm just trying to keep
with the times and you know me i'm woke
as [ __ ]
[Music]
don't some people call me a space cowboy
rabbit damn damn damn help some people
call me maurice
that song sucks and everyone knows it
some people call me
excited for my shows coming up dude
i'm very excited for my show is coming
up dude
i do like 50 minutes
i watch a new uh house of dragons in the
new game of thrones [ __ ] house of
dragons and [ __ ] and like i try so hard
you know i'm on my tutor [ __ ] right
like you know i'm on my tutor [ __ ] like
i'm when i watch that [ __ ] jonathan rice
reads my have two names by the way
you're a kind of an [ __ ] if you're
like oh
you're actually it's rice in the middle
reese
come on dude you know you're not
actually in those old times i get it
when you were like
[ __ ] sir henry the [ __ ]
yadda yadda
but like come on of right of a place
start calling me [ __ ]
chris of beverly hills like [ __ ] off if
you know
chris of beverly hills that's me dude
beverly hills
crystalia of beverly hills
so uh yeah dude so uh i'm watching so
i'm like i'm on my tutor [ __ ] okay and
i'm watching about it not only do i
watch about the tutors i pause it and
then i start googling about what's going
on
what actually happened with henry the
eighth right because i'm smart i don't
just sit and i watch a show like a bear
i'm smart i do research afterwards okay
um
and so i'm watching tutors and uh
every time i say tutors i think of
[ __ ] people who fart like toot
i'm watching
[Laughter]
hello we have to behead you now
now that's the essence of this podcast
right there
hello look what look what your majesty
look what we are gifting to your majesty
a chalice
wow
this is one for the ages
hello chancellor
yes
[Music]
what beautiful fabric on that
[Music]
off with us for a head
um so and then the executioner while he
does it
and then when the guy lops his head up
just so much [ __ ] tooting going on
tutors
see this is why i like having a [ __ ]
podcast by myself with no one else on it
because they would just [ __ ]
interrupt and [ __ ] and the bit would get
all weird
um
so uh
yeah if i'm on my tudor [ __ ] and then
kristen's like oh that [ __ ] house of
dragon [ __ ] is and i'm like what is that
i was like is this a new reality show i
don't even know and she's like it's that
game of thrones thing but it's 300 years
earlier and i'm like dude i didn't even
like game of thrones now i gotta watch
not even after it before it it's gonna
be more boring they got less [ __ ]
probably as time moves on there's more
[ __ ] and i gotta watch the prequel to
something where they barely had anything
except dragons that didn't even show up
until the [ __ ] fifth season by the
way dude
fourth season whatever it was dude i
[ __ ] watched it and there were no
dragons and then by the fourth season
there was finally like one or two
dragons and i was like this is what i've
been waiting for i'm out dude i'm out
and people about to think they're like
dude you were you you left right when it
gets good hey
four seasons
if i [ __ ] order a burger and 11 bites
are bad i'm done
now keep eating bro just wait
[Music]
i [ __ ] up with that burger
so i'm watching the [ __ ] uh
so she's like let's put it on come on
and she doesn't even want to watch it in
the [ __ ] room i want to watch it in
which is the worst bro
you know i'm like can we just watch it
with the fireplace and have it nice we
don't even want the fireplace on as hot
as [ __ ]
and our air conditioning doesn't work
but i'm like can we just have it on the
in the [ __ ] and where the fireplace
is dude and uh and she's like no i want
to watch it like where this is and i'm
like [ __ ] god and and the show i
don't want to watch
but okay though dude you know what i
mean
even though we did color me mine and i
didn't really want to do that and yes i
had a good time and a lovely time with
my son and i did that
and that wasn't one of my things that i
wanted to do yeah i still [ __ ] said
okay and we watched the show in
the room that i didn't want to watch and
that's fine but i sucked it up and i
watched it and dude i can't i don't know
what it is about this [ __ ] i cannot pay
attention to these kinds of shows for
more than four [ __ ] seconds
it's it's like there's so much brown in
it
[Laughter]
dude and it's like you know there's a
voiceover for sure and then like a
dragon and then like i'm like i you know
what it's just like in the house of
dragon targaryen and that's when it and
the in 300 years and the [ __ ] and
you're just watching this [ __ ] and
you're like
all right
okay and then a guy walks in with long
as [ __ ] blonde hair and you're like all
right no it's white sorry long [ __ ]
white hair and you're like oh cool all
right that's kind of an interesting
looking guy
and then it cuts to the other guys
talking to and the other guy's got long
as [ __ ] white hair
and they just are like talking to each
other
and then they say well like we have to
talk to the other guy in the [ __ ]
other room and then they go to another
room and there's [ __ ] three guys and
they all got like long white hair and
then a black guy comes in and he's got
long white hair and i'm just like
they're not nobody's gonna say anything
about this long white hair in the
beginning of i understand they live with
it but say something for us
it's like when when when jason mamoe is
in a movie this is what my brother
always says but like when jason momoa is
in a movie why aren't there at least two
or three scenes
in every one of his movies where
somebody says whoa dude you're huge
you're huge
let's get past he's too big to be in
movies you know
jason momoa is going to just like play a
guy
but you're seven feet tall 980.
but you're way more than a humvee too
sorry sir
you weigh more than a
than an h2
jason mamoa is so jason momoa that one
time i saw jason momoa before he was a
movie star when i just knew about a guy
that got a part to the new conan movie
and i saw him and i thought oh that's
jason momoa and i was right
and that is the god's honest truth dude
and i was with brian cowan and he walked
up to me he was like wow man you're a
big dude i swear to god you know he's
obsessed with bodies but that's what
happens when jason mama walks into a
room
maybe if he's aquaman okay he's a
superhero but dude you know
if he's just a guy with a gun and [ __ ]
like he's in a movie with sylvester
stallone i saw on a plane one because
that is one plane watching ass movie
dude i mean if you're gonna watch
what are the most two actors that you
would watch that would be in a movie in
a plane
because that's the thing too it's like
it wouldn't be the number one
it wouldn't be like
like you think of a [ __ ] a jeremy
renner movie you think oh that's a big
movie star i would go to the movie
theater for him because i love him right
but then if you couple him with with a
certain person
you might be like i'll wait for that at
home
dude it's very few stars that have that
all go no matter what
right no matter who they're coupled with
like you know what i mean
wow that's [ __ ] hilarious
like if you [ __ ] couple like
jason if you go see jason mamon movie
you might go to the theater because it's
gonna be aquaman it's gonna be whatever
the [ __ ] dune
if you see a sylvester stallone movie
maybe not now but back in the day dude
you would go it would be a blockbuster i
love sylvester stallone but you put
those both [ __ ] in a movie and
that [ __ ] is best seen on a screen
that's eight by 12.
but jason i'm always just gonna play a
guy with a gun that walks in a warehouse
and sylvester stallone's not gonna be
like whoa this guy's really big huh
he's just gonna be like hey
huh
so do it for us
house of dragons
well it's because we've all got white
hair right and that's why because we all
got really really [ __ ] there was the
age of
the age of of terrify remember that when
the [ __ ] when the when when the devil
himself rose up and scared all of our
ancestors and everyone went white hair
and that's what happened and now we all
have the white hair anyway who will we
be heading
[Music]
for real sounds just like tutors dude
chrisley.com
but yeah man
so
uh i don't know man but they you know
maybe they didn't they did a lot of
violence back then
but
i don't know man i don't know about that
house of dragons
with the targaryens or whatever the [ __ ]
they're called
like
i don't understand that that's the thing
about i don't
part of it is okay magic i'm not really
into shows with magic all right period
the second a wizard shows up i'm like
okay unrelatable
right
um
or like you know
like i'm not really into that kind of a
thing i'm not into magic i'm not into
like
sorcery i'm not into somebody who can
like [ __ ] i'm not into like a woman
who predicts the future that everybody
has to go to in a tower to find out
what's gonna happen
and also if you're gonna make up
a [ __ ] like uh a com
this is look the story is all [ __ ]
right like it it didn't happen
right this is all [ __ ] it's from
some really creatively [ __ ] guy's mind
right
some real like you know
just
i don't know he looks like
he would work at a [ __ ] hardware
store that tolkien guy or what and
that's not even him it's the other guy
but whatever
um
and so
you're gonna make up [ __ ] right just
that's what it is in its true form it's
actual [ __ ] so
that's fine
but why
why are you making everybody's name
so hard to remember
and and and and letters that are
together that are never together
were you like trigeria to chair jared
jiren jiren
terrarian cherberian
carebearian
what the [ __ ] is that guy who is he
again and they all got white hair so you
don't know who's who so like work with
me you know what i mean
if i'm gonna sit and watch the show
name him [ __ ] frank drebin
hello hi frank hello todd
whoa
let let's let's go let's go on the
[ __ ] track
okay todd shall we grab lisa
lisa who
lisa
lisa smith
well yes that's right
it's not that i forgot her name because
it's very easy to remember it's that i
actually [ __ ]
just didn't know it
but like why why why
because it makes it better i guess right
that's hilarious and then they got shows
like the two like the tutors where
[ __ ] henry k not henry cable he's in
it
henry um
harry k k styles jonathan rhys meyers
what the [ __ ] is playing henry the
eighth and just they just didn't wear a
fat suit or dye his hair red he was just
like no
which is hilarious
like hey guy
he's a real person in history and he
didn't do [ __ ] about it just walking
around all handsomely [ __ ]
henry viii
was a six foot three fat
[ __ ] he was ugly as [ __ ]
i don't know why john the reason why i
was gonna play he was supposed to put on
like a fat suit and makeup and
prosthetics and he was just like nah i'm
not doing that you want me to do the
part i'll [ __ ] do it my way and he
did it and that's it and then henry
cavill is in it everyone in the [ __ ]
show is so attractive and let me tell
you something dude i don't actually
necessarily think henry cavill is my
type of [ __ ] sexy right like i don't
[ __ ] guys but if i was gonna henry
cavill would would not be one that i did
right he just seems to
much a guy
that would be like on a date and be like
so what music do you listen to and
you're just like this
hip hop
hugo
right
and i happen to actually you know it's
interesting enough because i i i have
been into um dance music that has come
out uh in the late 90s i've been really
i don't know if it's the nostalgia of it
all like and i would just be like oh
dude
boner removal
oh dude induce me a little more
right make me go bracket kagak your face
works fine
let the combo initiate some brachika
cack
but jonathan rhys meyer seems like a
kind of a sexy dude that i might want to
like you know
do that [ __ ] with if i did [ __ ] guys
right
because i'd be like
on a date with him and he'd be like
where the [ __ ] is the waiter
and you'd be like i don't know he's
coming and he's like place [ __ ] you
know it's not one thing that they need
to be good at and i'm like all right bro
you got a little bit of an edge to you
don't you dude don't you right
and then you know it's [ __ ] runk city
horizontally
so uh
yeah but you know i'm not gay so that's
never gonna happen but my point is
i watched three seasons of the tudors
and i'm in first season not gonna lie
very boring might as well be watching a
[ __ ] like that tiny desk [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] everyone pretends to
like
right
people are like oh no but like you'll be
like dude tiny desk is hilarious they'll
be like yeah did you see the usher one
huh
no
no i didn't see
usher on tiny desk
did you
when he goes [ __ ]
watch this
that meme
[ __ ] laid me out dude
when he goes
watch this dude when he did that that
meme i just go like this oh i didn't
even laugh i go cool
and a priest came over
forget it dude watch this
and then the memes were just oh my god
dude
i should post some but um
yeah dude so uh i don't watch tiny desk
and i might as well watch tiny desk if
you want to watch the first season of
the tudors but then the second season of
the tudors
finally it started getting going and
that's 11 12 episodes in and then the
third season was good you know and i'm
watching henry cavill and i'm like this
guy
is a salad eating [ __ ] you know
just a [ __ ]
just he's toast you know
like you don't every just [ __ ] toast
you gotta put butter or jam on it but
this guy's just toast you know like he
is good looking
but everything he's you know what i mean
that comes out of his aura is just like
i was in a toaster for 10 seconds and
that's it
and you're like
and then season four starts
and they let his hair grow out
and his beard grow out dude
it's amazing what a little facial hair
can do to a guy that's [ __ ] that is a
salad eating [ __ ] i mean i
wouldn't even go on a date with him we
would be on tinder and match and then
i'd go right to his [ __ ] castle and
do the runcity
i mean he looks great okay so henry
cavill hats off to you for figuring it
out
you know jonathan rhys meyers and
[ __ ] henry cavill hated the [ __ ] out
of each other doing that whole thing
like because they were just both two
good looking dudes and henry cable
really didn't give a [ __ ] but jonathan
reese myers was like oh he's in the
scene again all right cool
oh he's oh he's in this one too great i
thought he was gonna be the other old
guy we could have used him but it's fine
i guess it you know it doesn't matter
it's my dialogue that matters
can we get a stool for me to stand on
i need to be taller than them
how much are they both five eight
dude did you watch imagine saying
someone sincerely to someone sincerely
did you see usher on tiny desk
dude imagine actually
[ __ ]
having those words come out of your
mouth towards someone else
hey do you see usher on tiny desk
tiny desk should not be as big as it is
okay
first of all
where are you shooting this
is this in a public library
and why is usher
mac miller john mayer and [ __ ]
you know uh uh
katy perry doing this
why isn't it people like nelly furtado
and again
where are you filming this
it's i don't i'm not i mean oh sure dude
watch this
these are my confessions
and energy zones and broken chains and
vengeance in the freakings and zones and
my confessions does anyone know the
words to any song for real that's so
weird when people do you know
i don't know any words to any songs i
only know some of them
it's always like
i'd start off as hot as [ __ ] you know
like i'm good like it'll be like
uh
[ __ ] this is how we do it it's
everyone knows that right this is how we
do it it's friday night the feeling's
right and the party is here on the west
side and then what and i'm reaching i'm
back and i'm feeding my bodies i'm in
that event and i'm picks up my cup and
you know a few and then i got best stuff
and you know this part right because i'm
faded
and then that's it
ever since i was a lowercase g and
that's it that's all you know dude
if you know any more than that
you know
get a job
i get why you guys listen to this
podcast man you know sometimes it's uh
off the rails it feels it's a bit off
the rails but that's what's up and i was
talking to rick glassman on t and taking
shoes off this week and he was like
doing a solo podcast it's very very hard
he's tried to do it and he doesn't like
it he can't do it and uh you know i
think that we have something in common
because i think i can't do it too and it
is very hard but i do it and i am so
[ __ ] i'm gonna say something that
annoying people say blessed that you
guys are here listening to me man
um
really really appreciate you let's look
at this thing here what we got
do we have
things up on this [ __ ]
um
this was crazy i thought uh
oh wow one fire didn't check off all the
stuff we're talking about on fire check
them all off so i know what i've talked
about and then do it and he's doing it
now and that's too late now it's all
good but it's too late he's checking
them and it's all good it's too late
it's fine because all i see are
unchecked [ __ ] things that i haven't
talked about i have seven things it's
not hard all good but one fire okay now
one thing that now he's checking him
like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he just
checked calvin messing up pronouns and
new game of thrones and by the way
that's it not the other ones
take your shoes off already talked about
that
you checked it ah there we go it's
updating okay here we go one thing
that's not checked which is something i
really want to talk about is idris elba
you just elvin dude first of all
runk city
he just is the hottest man in the world
okay
uh he's also the hottest woman in the
world i mean this guy just got it
[ __ ] going on how good
does idris elba
smell
for real
how good
does idris elba he smells so good
that like sometimes
people actually get a whiff and pass out
like in a good way
they go oh my god that's actually
and he goes all right and just keeps
walking
sorry i'd stop but i'm on my set to dj
i've got a dj for some reason because
i'm a dj for some reason
uh i'm i'm not even lying how much
[ __ ] molly does idris elba do dude he
does so much molly i guarantee it i
guarantee
that if you're at hollywood events idris
uh you just elba is on so much molly and
always alone
and just sweating and his [ __ ] cuffs
are opened you know and he's just like
all right hey i saw you i saw you i saw
you down there i saw you down there it
was really great man you go check out my
new movie beast
and then moon walks away
so this thing is on deadline and
i gotta you know
whoa dude house of dragons draws 10
million viewers in debut best ever for
hbo and hbo max originally shows 10
million views in one day and i was one
of them and i turned it off
no actually crystal watched it twice so
cool they got two of her that was mine
that counted as mine so idris elba on
daughter not this is the [ __ ] uh
headline idris elba on daughter not
speaking to him for weeks after not
getting role in beast movie so he's in
that new movie called beast for some
reason and i know why money right cause
idris alba is in some [ __ ] really
good [ __ ] and he's always really good
and now all of a sudden he's doing a
movie where his co-star is a lion
so i'm just like
money
okay idris if you're in a movie and your
co-star is a lion and it's not
and the soundtrack isn't by [ __ ]
elton john
money
right
so
so here's what happened dude idris elba
is sharing the tense environment he
lived through after his daughter
isan didn't land a role in his latest
movie beast for lack of chemistry on
camera
uh
now
see this is just what the media does
dude yourself on daughter not speaking
him for weeks after not getting rolling
beats movie now that's the line that's
the thing you want to click on it and
then it says
sharing the tense moment after didn't
land the role nice
and it says interestingly enough he says
it interestingly enough my daughter
auditioned for this role elba said
during an appearance on the breakfast
club she wants to be an actress and she
auditioned and it came down to chemistry
in the end the relationship in the film
did and the relationship between my
daughter was
the chemistry wasn't right for the film
weirdly enough
um
after not getting the party he said that
they didn't talk for weeks
um i'm sure it was a joke
or not
but the way the headline is makes it
seem like they had a real falling out
which is annoying it was producer
a different producer that gave
isan the news
um
she was doing the role
audition for the role of his
little niece i guess
uh and then was like and then elba
didn't go
didn't throw a fit about like well no i
want my daughter in it which is cool
for him to do that um
you know i don't know it's tough there
is nepotism in the business that's why i
like that i do stand up man because i
know my dad's in the business but
you know
nobody's [ __ ] laughing in the room
because of my dad i mean nobody knows
who my dad is when i'm in [ __ ] grand
st prairie or [ __ ] dallas or wichita
this weekend or [ __ ] dc the next one
you know
um
so yeah dude hey it's not cause i it's
not cuz i'm my dad's son that i can
[ __ ]
shake a room you know what i mean hey
guys that's it for today on the youtube
episode if you want to catch the rest of
the episode all you got to do is go
check out our patreon
patreon.comcristalia
and uh there's uh
the raw uncut rest of the episode for
every episode that we ever do so it's
much longer and then also we have an
extra episode a month and if you sign up
today for only six dollars that gives
you access to all the past episodes that
you can't get not on patreon so that's
like 16 episodes go
binge and watch them but and then we do
review mode and we do other stuff i did
a little sit down with kristin you get
access to that um and we're always
trying to perfor provide more content so
thanks a lot guys and have a good
[Music]
thank
one